- [Voiceover] So, here we have the graph
y is equal to g of x.
We have a little point
discontinuity right over here
at x is equal to seven,
and what we want to do is figure out
what is the limit of g of
x as x approaches seven.
So, since you say, well, what
is the function approaching
as the inputs in the function
are approaching seven?
So, let's see, so if we input
as the input to the function
approaches seven from
values less than seven,
so if x is three, g of three is here,
g of three is right there,
g of four is right there,
g of five is right there, g of six
looks like it's a little bit more than,
or a little bit less than negative one,
g of 6.5 looks like it's
around negative half,
g of negative 6.9 is right over there,
looks like it's a little
bit less than zero,
g of negative 6.999 looks
like it's a little bit,
it's still less than zero
but it's a little bit
closer to zero so it looks
like we're getting closer
as x gets closer and closer
but not quite at seven,
it looks like the value of our function
is approaching zero.
Let's see if that's also true from values
for x values greater than seven,
so g of nine is up here,
looks like it's around six,
g of eight looks like it's
a little bit more than two,
g of 7.5 looks like it's a
little bit more than one,
g of 7.1 looks like it's a
little bit more than zero,
the g of 7.1 looks like it's
a little bit more than zero,
g of 7.01 is even closer to zero,
g of 7.0000001 looks like
it'll be even closer to zero
so once again it looks like
we are approaching zero
as x as approaches seven,
in this case as we approach
from larger values of seven.
And this is interesting because the limit
as x approaches seven of
g of x is different than
the function's actual value, g of seven,
when we actually input
seven into the function.
When we actually input
seven into the function,
we can see the graph tells us
that the value of the function
is equal to three.
So we actually have this
point discontinuity,
or sometimes called a
removable discontinuity,
right over here, and this is,
I'm not gonna do a lot of depth here,
but this is starting to touch on how we,
one of the ways that we can
actually test for continuity
is if the limit as we approach
a value is not the same
as the actual value of the
function of that point,
well, then we're probably talking about,
or actually we are talking
about, a discontinuity.